Okay. Let's go to some notable discussions
from the David Pakman show subreddit, which
you can of course find at David pakman.com/reddit
now boasting nearly 16,000 subscribers from
our online radio, television, and satellite
television audiences. Last week I, uh, some
notable discussions I want to go over. Last
week I did a story about the divisions on
the left and there was a faction of the left
that I said, you know, sometimes I call this
the Leninist left. Sometimes they are called
tankinis, but I find those terms pejorative.
I would like to have some other way to refer
to this group. And there's a post on our subreddit
which says, David, you should call the Lennon
is left hankies. It's not bad to be confrontational
to ignorant people. Tankers are not just people
who espouse far left views. They are people
who hate the West and like Russia, China,
Iran, North Korea, over the U S and European
union.
These people support Tulsi Gabard because
of her isolation, his stances, and even make
false claims that she is anti-Israel. Okay,
so listen, I think that there's a case to
be made that the term may not be an inaccurate
one to call some of these folks hankies or
Lennon is left. My point is I don't think
it's productive because the term is pejorative
and I got a bunch of emails about this and
the consensus was I should be calling that
wing of the left, the revolutionary left or
the Marxists left. Now Marxists left. I'm
unsure of because I don't know that the entire
Leninist left is literally Marxists. They're
also not literally net Leninist so maybe it
doesn't matter if a, the term literally applies
to everyone. Revolutionary left may actually
be a good term to non pejoratively. Describe
that slice of the left. Let me know what you
think.
Also, much follow up about the discussion
we had earlier this week about debates with
Charlie Kirk, the right wing bomb thrower
from turning point USA as well as my absence
at Politiken. This user says David needs to
do a public debate despite the WWE pro wrestling
vibes. I just watched the political debate
between Kyle Kalinsky and Charlie Kirk and
it was frustrating. Both of them got applause
when they made points. I felt Kyle was correct
on substance, but he lost key letting Kirk
and Gish Gallop a lot and could have used
more of his time to make his case. Even though
he did a great job of demonstrating his consistent
principles and criticizing policies of both
parties. He lost his cool way too often, almost
to the point of coming across as whiny. I
don't know if David has experienced with these
kinds of debates, but he's very much in control
of everything when he has guests on who disagree
with him.
Yeah. Listen, I am flattered by people saying,
David, you would have done way better than
Kyle in this scenario. I really don't know
that that's the case and I'm not playing pho
humble. I mean the those types of situations
can go any number of ways that when the crowd
gets involved, when the moderator plays or
doesn't play a particular role, it's not clear
to me. My, my, what I feel very strongly about
is that this is not a format overall in terms
of the timing structure, role of the moderator
and role of the audience that leads to actual
productive discussions. Counterpoint. We are
in right now producing a four interview series
with this guy Juran Brooke from the iron Rand
Institute. I'm not a Randian as many of you
know, I'm not a libertarian or any of this
stuff. I disagree with. You're on Brooklyn
almost every everything. But we have set these
up so that they will be for 30 to 40 minute
conversations each with a specific topic,
no interrupting where we can actually give
our views and argue against the other's views.
I think that that is going to be a format
that much better will serve learning and figuring
out which ideas reigned Supreme for lack of
a better term, and a reference of course,
uh, to iron chef so that, that's where all
sort of leave it. Make sure you're subscribed
to the David Pakman show subreddit. It's free
and more than 15,000 of you have already done
it. David pakman.com/r. E. D. D I. T.